so yes shit I was like the second to
last pardon holy fuck like if they just
put a VN at the end it's just like it's
open-ended open to your interpretation
I'm cool that like that was enough but
there's another fairy been hilarious
yeah everyone would have been pissed but
we've been like holy crap so uh
obviously this is the signal last
episode rob want to join for this cuz
this is the the big finale and uh yeah
holy shit that's all I can really say do
it I just watching it you go first I'm
gonna have an opinion apparently until
you say something so I didn't say the
Hutchins no but everyone else did oh
okay well they did them I don't care uh
but no pretty much like so okay my
imagination when people build stuff up
or say oh this is so scarier oh this is
so epic girl this is so funny like I
really hype up a lot in my imagination
and I search train myself to say okay
it's probably not gonna be as good as
you thought it was gonna be so I kind of
thought this would be the same cuz
you're thinking wrong there's a lot of
epic battles you can do maybe who's kind
of a gap epic belt is gonna that the
battle is done this is really like you
can just see where like the budget for
the season went
it just went to these last two of those
Koreans work overtime ya know I mean
they probably got handed this it were
just like are you insane it's like okay
here's how the seasons gonna work we're
gonna really dull the palette it's gonna
be like a lot of reds and grays but it's
okay it's the darker one we have a lot
of character development so it means a
lot of not moving and standing still and
really you're going a couple fill up
risotto one or two you know just to you
know just to buy us some time
and then it's all gonna go on this shit
and now render me a fool air fleet yeah
I mean it's an Ltd environment
put your 2d characters into it I want a
fleet of 3ds up and they've blended well
I mean it's though the render on the
actual shits I mean it was a touch
choppy by it it's a Nickelodeon show I
know people are like oh why do you have
to say that say it's a Nickelodeon show
cause it
is even the good really good Nickelodeon
shows now you're like ice on TV but I
mean it's like do for a show like this
to be like you know anime at least give
the appearance of like high budget anime
action shows that you get from Japan or
like a movie or muse I don't say anime
and this would be higher end even in
Japan yeah I mean this is everything
really low-budget animes yeah I mean so
so this is like holy shit uh so I don't
know I'm still floored by this I'm just
floored by the show in general and this
climax is just even more of a testament
to because it's just how did this show
get done I mean how did it get this big
and how did they budget it and how do
they plan it how did they put this all
the MCZ animators lots of overtones I'm
just talking about that on top the story
matches everything it just leads into
this and everything feels justified um
the the one thing that what especially I
noticed this time to that first I'm
sorry like I was having a little issue
with but I realize it really comes
together is the showing the three
generations of the fire Lords including
inkling Azula now you know technically
she did become the Fire Lord but you see
the most there but but you see the
progression you have uh you get the fire
lord ozai ridge '''l what was it air bag
the last avatar that they had you know
and he kills him up but you see the
friendship there and he granddaddy Fire
Lord
yeah I mean he's not totally nuts he has
this vision and it's a skewed and it's
gonna really be costly I mean he kind of
kicad goes all nothing you see he has
this intention of like you know bringing
this order this good order it just
happens to be my order and those who
Doris damn kill him it's like okay yes
that's where the crazy part comes in but
you understand that it's like he wants
to do it because it's like we could be
one world and then you go to like you
know the Mark Hamill Fire Lord who's
like sources
yeah who saw this evil genius who really
just wants the power he just wants the
power element of he wants to control
everything yeah he doesn't want control
for the people he wants to control for
himself and then you get Azula the next
heir who is just now it's like one
generation crazy past own our generation
crazy past two just total bad shit and
say now and it's great cuz you see the
progression and the lack of commitment
of loving another and that's where so
much of this was coming from and you
even see when uh when mark hamill fire
looked like a babe I'm never gonna know
Ryan cuz you guys don't go nuts but Mark
Hamill fire-engines Ozai OSI oak at one
I dunno okay so so Ozai
you see when you saw his father and the
one where the the mother is banished uh
that even the father's like you know
what are you talking about you disgrace
you stupid blah blah blah I mean even
he's really talking down to um it you
know sort of justifiably so BC is really
talking down till you just see this
progression and as that as that anger
and the frustration passes down to each
generation generation and they get less
love put in them they just get crazier
and filled with more fear and it just it
worked out so perfect what seeing it a
second time now I was thinking about
that I had noticed it the first time
that what's really happening and there's
no spoiler here cuz you've already
noticed it is it's really the story of a
very dysfunctional I would say very
mentally ill family yeah and it starts
with the grandfather cuz I know I know
you
um it's like well he had a vision and if
you're gonna let your best friend die oh
you know he's still not yeah ty majeski
nuts and that insanity just seems to
plague and it's almost like a commentary
on the way insanity seems to run in
families and it's a chicken in the egg
is are they really insane or is this one
abusive relationship just creating
another and another and but for the
grace of God with Zuko go I mean I think
Iroh is the one who is able to sort of
keep Zuko in check but I mean we've seen
what Zuko was earlier
in the in the first season I mean that
could have been Azula well I mean you
have two siblings here too you have you
know you have Iroh and you have um
Mark Hamill 500 zyo psyche yeah Iroh and
you have Ozai and you know one goes
really fucking not together you know it
seems to me for the most part pretty
level-headed was possibly a little nuts
at first because I mean he was leaving
this couch at a moment I think that's
the thing is they all have a meal I
changed them Zuko had his moment that
changed him and I Rohan his so they each
sort of encountered that moment I think
another thing is if you look at Zuma and
Zuko I think one of the issues is
because Azula is crazier I think there's
some part of Zuko that eventually if you
give them the right shove will rebel
against that the way some kids will
rebel against their parents if their
parents are conservative they'll be
liberal with their liberal sometimes
they'll be conservative and I think
that's the case partially with Zuko is I
think he's able to look at a zoo and go
holy crap like if but for the grace of
God that could be me you know they're
going nuts and I think so much of it too
probably I need oh don't like if you go
back and find different I understand but
uh all these characters serve in this
fire Lord family uh have these failings
they have these major failings as
whether or not they let themselves to be
ruled by those failings what even if
it's just fear of someone you know sulla
got that scene where she sees the mother
in the mirror and obviously she's a
little bit freaky no no but she forces
that hallucination to say that she loves
her it's like that's the saddest fucking
thing as much as you wanna strangle
Azula that's to say a fucking thing and
that's her big failing she could never
get the mother's love and she let that
rule her that's why Zuko broke the chain
is because he didn't let it ruin he did
he had his failing team with his failing
you know and excites but he broke Lou
and the thing is she's fighting herself
when that happens it's her
hallucinations of her hallucination is
saying no I loved you and just like no
ya know it's just such a great singing
bit yeah is the episode goes on it's
just like bong bong cuckoo hey okay you
know add animation ease episode the this
episode I'm sure the next one as well is
just unbelievable but uh just going to
like the character animation on Azula in
this I mean like just unbelievable just
how thick the The Strokes are and how
much they jar sort of like the Joker
almost and to get that hair you know
ragged and in front stick on wrong yeah
I mean it's just this wonderful and it's
one of those where it's like I love to
go back and sort of watch in slow motion
cuz I get the feeling it's erm Waldo's
where you see like a bunch of different
expressions going on and just like you
know the eye twitching you compare I see
it in there and it's just it's so well
done I mean just the end the nhin is
great but particularly on her as a
character in this it's just so wonderful
um God try think what the hell allows to
even talk about um well you're out of
ideas I'll come up with something only
thing I'll talk about in terms of could
this is such I be visually this episode
is just amazing and like I said all the
characters uh uh you know and come to
the this big climax and this big ending
is turning out wonderful uh you know the
color palette throughout a lot is there
in the fire nation so obvious there's
going to be a lot of red and you know
when the earth Kingdom there's a lot of
green and the waters a lot of blue red
as a primary color is tricky to pull off
when you have to be surrounded by it
because red is meant to stand out
against other primary colors that's why
it's used in advertising cuz red isn't
everywhere but when it starts become
everywhere it can sort of become an
eyesore and then you start get tired of
looking at it but here man that with the
comet coming in and they use the fire
the different colors of the fire and the
way just the palette of oranges and
yellows and stuff I mean just this
episode looked amazing just from a
colorful point of view and just on top
of that it is book three fire yeah I
mean but it's one of those where it's
like I got it it's or it had to be
darker there in the bad guy territories
there's gonna be a lot right and
sometimes it really worked I mean it's
not like this was a failure of color
it's not that it's that it was supposed
to be darker but there's kind of only so
long you look at just red and gray but
here it's just like
sort of like in that one episode where
they show the Dragons blowing the
different colors of fire it's sort of
like that you see the different colors
of red and the different blends you can
do and it just made it look good the
color was extremely well done um the
interesting thing um I'm sure you
noticed it Azula is not red she's blue
yeah no they they have a yes right she's
absolutely not only is a great choice
because it separates her from Zuko
but in those scenes in the palace where
she's going crazier and crazier the blue
flame gives it this really deathly
almost sort of dead body morgue
esque glow to it yeah looks sickly it
looks wet it looks sickly almost like
she's in a tomb and it's just brilliant
because every time you see her she just
says this ghostly blue glow around her
that separates her from the rest of sort
of the Fire Nation red colour and then
when you get into the battle itself
you've got her with this sort of blue
color and the blue going goes the you
know yeah
taking out Zucco's uh orange I wonder if
they had a chance to go back cuz I know
wasn't always blue the flame wasn't
always blue uh in the other episodes I
went ahead she has to go back if they
were redone bad no cuz I think the
reason they did it I don't know a real
reason why I did it but one of my
theories is that
and she goes more nuts he wanted to
separate her from the rest of the pack
and I think it does that because she's
not I mean she's always crazy but the
level of nuts
she's a good rover self yeah and that
color scheme happens over the course of
the episode so that you know when you
you went from one point where she seemed
really powerful and now when you see her
she's just gone completely insane
that blue now is just surrounding her
and it changes the whole way her
character sort of looks and feels I
think it was really intentional no
you're probably right because as she
gets more mentally ill the fight you're
right the fire changes color and becomes
less warm and more cold and thus it
probably not as strong either yeah it
kind of does bring that airship battle
with Sokka yeah God the ships hitting
I'm just gonna occupy Grenoble when the
shoots are in
since attending competition anybody's
game is incredible um yeah trying I
think there's anything else in this
episode apart from Mark Hamill being
awesome and everybody being awesome it
uh I am calling you out on that one
moment though where you tried to compare
it to DBZ and I'm like no oh no yeah no
I don't know why or not just compare
this to deep the Firelord comes you know
stands on the bottom that egg is there
he stands on the mound and he's like
glowing fire inside just at next time on
Dragon Ball Z and you're just like you
motherfucker no do not bring that up
here this is too good but uh no I I'm
blown away imagined and this is only
part one I mean I oh the music okay that
was a music stand yeah okay music
probably some of the best music in the
whole series is right in these last two
episodes spoiler alert the music's gonna
be good in the last episode - hope I
didn't ruin it for dumb um you've been
reading the comments you know what I
love yeah you remember what I supposed
to be spoiled that's the beauty of it no
I don't want you so no I don't remember
oh how dare you give it away and I'm
like I know him shame on me remembering
one episode later shame on you yeah boy
I watch my stuff as much as I do I think
it had something to do with so since
comment that that's all I remember
but it comes but uh yeah the music in
this episode and the music in the next
episode are incredible particularly the
battle music I I love this thing they've
got going with Ozai when he's jumping
towards Aang and you got these like
little psycho strings like this and then
when it cuts to the battle between Azula
and Zuko the music there's just gorgeous
is like just takes a sort of
otherworldly up like it just elevates it
I was like no we're just gonna do
something sort of calm and just sad it's
just very sad yeah and they turn down
the sound for when they're actually
doing the fire and the screaming and
yelling of stuff I know which was very
smart and I think the reason works so
effective here as well
is that you're gonna cut to the loud
stuff and the explosions and you
angel anymore muted so so you can go
back and forth answer cause I'm trapped
yeah cuz anga Nosa is a very loud battle
in the end sucka and Sookie and the
tough that's a loud battle yeah so it'll
really have this more quiet warrior
it's a good trick though I see it used
sometimes and it's really effective I
because I think there's some
similarities um to me reminds me that
bit in return to the Jedi where Luke
faces off against Vader where Luke goes
nuts and then the music just going yeah
the music takes over entirely to the
point that there is lightsaber sounds
but it's like they tuned it down a bit
and let the music just take over and
then the choir do something somewhere
here and it really really works and
again I separates that scene I think
that really works in something like this
where there's a couple climaxes going on
so they can really offset each other if
that was it I say wow that was ballsy
that was a risky move it's like this is
the big climax
I want my testosterone filled stuff come
on with the explosion sounds a step by
having them all going at the same time I
think you just had this you sort of
satisfy everybody um yeah and then the
last sort of thing I'll say just cuz it
was going Toph made the Iron Man suit
that was cool
I have to okay I'm not calling bullshit
but there's one thing that I don't I'm
not sure they addressed it but when she
does that I'm kind of like you know
metal conducts heat to be like is
they're gonna like is there some
cutscene where she can where she comes
to a complete stop and then they bend
open the metal and she's completely
roasted on it most if they can freeze
water she can cool metal I guess I'm
doing it from the inside
yeah I it's it doesn't wreck it it's a
kid show but yeah I always yeah I always
look at the door my jumpers with Webb
yeah but it's like man if I put a pan
over an open flame it doesn't take long
before it's like and they're like
blasting fire that's directed or can you
pick me pick me yeah but it's like yes
it's like who gives a shit it was
awesome this is it so what yeah I think
the one last little bang maybe this was
just me but the scene where Ozai
unleashes hell fire upon the earth
Kingdom that hurt
assistance every time I like I've seen
that like two or three times on every
time I just cringe like
Oh douchebag like because you've just
gotten to know these kingdoms and the
characters and the spirit world and the
animals and he's just fucking laying
waste to it you know it's okay though
because at least one member of the Fire
Nation got his birthday acknowledged and
I think that makes it all okay Anup
email what's my birthday that's my
favorite scene and the fact that it
works yeah like if this is the plan that
is so stupid it just asks about the
Sacco moment I was saying like you know
they're certainly trying to choose fear
they're trying to teach him the sword
I'm just like great but they're like oh
what's not good good for like he's good
for a lot of thing well what's this oh
he does nothing it's like it's that
great out of the box thank you my boys
yeah he's always good at thing out his
feet as I have tried to take out that
entire crew one by one and like you know
bend them to death he's like I got this
it's a gravel probably drown yeah that
always goes like hmm they're all wearing
metal suits of armor Oh water is just
like fluffy pillows and cartoons now I
mean it's like no reaction when you hit
the water
everyone can swim to shore wherever they
are still making out moving up breathing
a few firebenders yeah that's that's
cartoon so uh yeah so where do you think
it's going I have no idea how he's gonna
get rid of the Fire Lord the only thing
I could think of like in my head I was
just like well maybe if you like cut off
the limbs you something like they're not
gonna do that telling me that I was like
oh man I forget obi-wan Kenobi and
Anakin and those eyes just like I drew
or like community at yourself or like
convinces him the somehow knock himself
I don't know how you would restrain the
guy maybe there's a way put him in rocks
or so it's like I don't know what he can
do the rock bent you know what he can't
so covering the rock I thought maybe
like those I was just gonna keep my
throwing fire Joe I'm tired just know
that sound or something it's like I
don't know I don't know how they're
gonna resolve and I really like that I
like not knowing
um so yeah I'm excited believers one
more laughs talk cuz I hate you I'm just
gonna give it away